make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay too powerful for Marvel movies
Monica Rambeau art she is powerful like
cheese powerful powerful uh and it's and
it's kind of crazy okay so one the clock
back to amazing spider-man annual number
sixteen which I think was released in
1987 and the idea was that Monica
Rambeau was basically introduced as the
new Captain Marvel for those guys who
don't know and this is one of the things
that that for not coming book readers
the the mantle of Captain Marvel can get
a little bit hairy but originally you
had Marvel write like this Kree soldier
from from the Kree planet of Halle who
is basically showing up on earth to see
whether on earth could be conquered and
then ultimately he turned coded and then
turned against you know the the Kree
Empire which sledded like his battle
with Y on Raw and all that kind of cool
stuff anyway the idea behind this was
that eventually Marvel died in 1984 the
death of Captain Marvel and what
happened was Marvel had the mantle of
Captain Marvel sitting open and so what
they did is they said okay we're gonna
create Monica Rambeau she's gonna be the
newest Captain Marvel now around that
time you did have Carol Danvers but
carol danvers was known as miss marvel
she wasn't actually Captain Marvel and
so because that like the mantle and
everything was sort of maintained and so
following that you eventually had the
introduction of genus Val who became the
new Captain Marvel and then you had
phyla Val who became the new Captain
Marvel and then finally like Carol
Danvers becomes Captain Marvel so there
were a lot of people who had the mantle
before like Carol Danvers did but
nonetheless so an amazing spider-man
annual number sixteen you end up having
a Monica Rambeau who's introduced and
she's got these powers calling herself
Marvel and one who's up happening is
later on down the line in the story you
end up finding out that she was
basically hit up by this guy who had
developed this kind of technology or at
least was working alongside this
scientist who worked for a dictator now
Andre LeClair was the the scientists
that originally hit up Monica Rambeau
and then he basically tells the story
about a guy named Philippe Picaro and
Philippe Picaro is basically a scientist
working for a dictator and Philippe is
essentially well real he's working for
rocks not oil but Philippe is basically
trying to find a way to like tap into
other universes and harness their energy
and so ultimately like Monica goes
underground or she goes kind of
undercover because she's basically a cop
at the time she goes undercover she ends
up basically you know getting the
attention of Philippe and then becomes a
subject of his experiment and what he
does is he basically bombards her with
all these energies unlike other
realities to see whether or not it can
work and what this does is it basically
transitions her body and turns her into
a state of pure energy now one of the
one
funny things about Monica and this is
kind of the crazy thing it's technically
she can manipulate every form of energy
that exists out there but she's almost
kind of like Nightcrawler in that regard
right like Billy guys who don't know
Nightcrawler when he teleports he
teleports to a different dimension and
then to where he wants to go right so
like it's called the brimstone dimension
so if Nightcrawler was sitting in Los
Angeles and wanted to go to Washington
DC he would teleport to the brimstone
dimension and then to wash it in DC
that's why you know that's why I like in
the comics he comes out smelling like
brimstone and while they're always kind
of seems to be like this sort of flames
surrounding him or like this kind of
fiery substance that surrounds him but
what ended up happening with Monica is
it's actually her mind that teleports
and so what happens is that because she
can access all these different forms of
energy electromagnetic ultraviolet gamma
rays and what essentially happens here
is her mind goes to this other dimension
and basically controls the energy from
that dimension in her physical body so
it's almost like she's playing a puppet
master for herself
now what this does is it makes Monica
Rambeau one of the most powerful
characters in in Marvel now I say that
within reason right like Monica Rambeau
is not a reality warper but one of the
best things about Monica is because she
can start shifting through different
forms of energy she has all the powers
and the principles of those energy so
like being able to hurt like turn into a
light wave she can literally travel at
the speed of light I guess it's crazy
when it comes to those kinds of powers
there was a moment an amazing spider-man
annual number 16 when she was able to
like literally blast Peter Parker with a
blast of energy and it seemed kind of
crazy because like his spider sense goes
off but she reacts faster than he can't
and like she's done that in a multitude
of instances right like there was one
point where it was one of the old of
injured stories I don't know which one
but there was one point where she flies
into space and she fixes all these
satellites and then flies back to earth
before the Avengers can take a breath
like that was it there was one point
where she fought magneto and she was
able to like become electromagnetic
energy and fly through magneto shield so
like literally for the most part almost
any form of energy that anybody uses at
least is if it's if it's like a
concussive form of energy which is to
say an energy that's physical that they
shoot at somebody else did like Monica
can learn to control it the only thing
that I would say would be kind of a
quagmire in a bit of a question here
would be somebody like Cyclops right
because for havoc it's basically solar
energy more or less and like because of
the fact you just basically light energy
she can in turn control it and use it
for her own ends but Cyclops shoots
energy out of his optic beams that comes
from a different dimension and it's a
dimension that like Monica's not from
that she's not familiar with and
so if her in Cyclops met in she blood
and Cyclops shot it with an optic beam I
would say like in the first skirmish he
would probably be able to injure her or
she have to turn into a form of energy
whereby it like passes through her right
so she's basically invaluable but like
at the same time if she learns to
understand how his energy works then she
can in turn control it and so if she's
surrounded by all the x-men and Cyclops
shoots off his optic beams she would in
turn be able to like control and split
the beams and they would hit all the
other x-men and take them out that's one
of the crazy things is like being able
to manipulate energy like that she was
able to sneak aboard the x-men's black
aura the x-men's blackbird without being
seen or heard she could make herself
invisible she can camouflage herself to
look like her surroundings she can bend
light around herself to look like other
people
it's crazy with the the level of power
she possesses like she's she's kind of a
Swiss Army knife but again that's one of
the crazy things is because if you go
and you read Al Ewing's Ultimates where
she's talking to Adam Brashear or at
least Adam Brashear starts to analyze
her powers one of the things he says is
like there's really no limit to what her
powers aren't and that's one of the big
caveat stores because because with her
being a member of the Avengers and
because the Avengers usually fought
earth-based threats which is to say
characters who were like really powerful
in their own right but they weren't like
cosmic threats because that doesn't
really happen you don't really see
Monica Rambeau
facing off against people who can like
manipulate all forms of energy or
something along something along those
lines but at the same time you'd have to
believe it was a stalemate because if
you have someone like Owen Reese for
example who can manipulate the molecular
structure of matter and then he goes to
face off against against you like Monica
Rambeau then on some level it could be a
stalemate depending on how far it gets
pushed now in reality you just like turn
her into a teacup right but like you're
talking about her being able to
manipulate almost every form of energy
that exists and so if it's in the
universe it's an energy she recognizes
which means that like everything
molecule man could do she could in some
form like set it back but we've never
seen her do that right like we've never
seen her face off against someone who
turned the Baxter building of the
Fantastic Four
or like the Empire State Building into
like a giant statue and then she shifted
it back but if she can control all these
forms of energy then it then she has to
go to control like the molecular form of
that energy if she can use it to her own
in and if she can then that in turn
would make her like Oh a manipulator of
that form of energy
everything is composed of energy being
able to manipulate all those forms of
energy make her insanely capable like
make her insanely powerful I don't
really know how else to say that
especially when you apply
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe because
the the power of of Carol Danvers in the
MCU is still not really readily
explained right like we don't know the
basis behind it I mean we know it's like
the result of an explosion but like we
don't really know like how all it works
we were looking at Carol you say okay
it's like she basically becomes binary
which we knew from the trailers and so
like she essentially like emits energy
and that's an energy source that Monica
recognizes Carol Danvers is defeated
because Monica will just turn her energy
against her is all that'll happen there
was there was one point where she fought
a villain who could use antimatter and
then in turn he put an antimatter field
around himself and so Monica Rambeau
just suffocated him inside of his own
forcefield because you couldn't get into
it it's small little things like that
like it's it's small little strange
abilities like that and that's what
that's what kind of makes her so cool
plus being astronomically fast and so if
you take Monica Rambeau and you throw
her into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
she would crush everybody including
Thanos like nobody would have a chance
just Sprott off the bat you're talking
about like being able to move at
Lightspeed and then being able to have
like strengths on par with being able to
face up against like she-hulk I bet all
the money in my pockets - all the money
in your pockets that while she Hulk
wouldn't necessarily be able to like
hold her own against Thanos she'd be
able to do a little bit better than fair
and so you're talking about like
somebody who is at least on par with she
Hulk's power if not a little bit
stronger
of course weaker than the Incredible
Hulk but then couple that was being able
to move it like light speed and so here
you're talking about like a battle of
attrition by the time dados landed one
or two hits on Monica she would have
landed thousands and so like the fight
would be over before it even started but
like you take a care to like that and
then you have her face off against Iron
Man well Iron Man uses electricity so
she just becomes electricity and shuts
down his suit or blows his suit up with
him in it with Thor I mean he has magic
but Magic Wallet is kind of a source of
energy in and of itself it's not
directly and I've never really seen
Monica be able to like control the
magical abilities of another person all
magic does and Marvel Comics is let you
tap into something else right so like
the ability to quote-unquote manipulate
magic is like using a hammer or using
like a shovel or something like that
it's a means to achieve an end it's
learning spells to achieve goals by
manipulating other things so like Doctor
Strange his enchantments don't really do
anything his enchantments let him tap
into the power of others which in turn
allows him to open a wormhole if that
makes any sense in like travel through
space but like when you're talking about
that like you're talking about Monica
Rambeau facing off against someone like
thwart I don't know she'd really be able
to be - I mean she has to turn into a
form of energy but again like being able
to move faster than light would problem
make that work with the Incredible Hulk
and gamma radiation because she can
manipulate that she would just draw all
the gamma radiation out of the
Incredible Hulk that would be the end of
that Captain America I mean he would be
readily defeated Black Widow Hawkeye
easily defeated I mean she's done things
like catch bullets because she's so fast
she's a powerhouse and it's one of the
funny things because by and large unless
you're a comic book reader Monica
Rambeau is obscure to you and unless you
read the old Avengers stories or next
wave she was probably obscurity the only
way you would really know who Monica
Rambeau is is if either you you go
through and like you read the old comics
you track the history of the Captain
Marvel where should be what she was
Captain Marvel then she became photon
and that should became pulsar I think it
was or if you read like Al Ewing's
Ultimates other than that like she's
really one of the more obscure
characters out there and it's one of
those scenarios where she was just never
really effectively written but in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe she would
single-handedly crush everybody should
be like a goddess maybe it'd be
absolutely bonkers it's really a
crapshoot because we've never seen
anybody like her in the model Cinematic
Universe and you don't really see her
fight the kind of characters you would
expect her to see to really like
showcase her various powers like it's
it's kind of one of the downsides like
having her face off against someone who
can manipulate reality and basically
manipulate energy in the extreme and
then see how she fares against that
person we've never really seen I would
love to see that where you throw her
into the MCU and she's gonna she's gonna
crush everybody like not even in hell
would you see a massacre like what you
would see if Monica Rambeau showed up in
the MCU anyway guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comment explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
robb for if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you